[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم
عليكم
التشريعيه المثال العمليه لمن قال اذا كان
الغراب دليل قوم فلا فلحوا ولا فلح الغراب
كيف يرى الرئيس القذات في عين خصومه على
كثرتهم ولا يرى الجذع في عين مشروعه الذي
لا يروق الا له و لثله ممن حوله رغم انه
لم يجر على تونس
العراق قيس سعيد من سندوب وهم يقفزون
الواحده تلو الاخر من مركبه الايه للغرق
ليس اولهم صادق بالعيد عهد اليه بدستور
سعيد وليس اخرهم نور الدين الطبوبي رئيس
الاتحاد التونسي للشغل الذي قال ان قيس
سعيد هو المشكله وان عليه التقاط الرساله
التي بعث بها التونسيون في هذه الانتخابات
لكن في المقابل من قال اني عزوف الناخبين
في الجوله الاولى سيتتكرروا في الجوله
الثانيه اليس حاليا بخصوم سعيد الانتظار
لحين انتهاء الجوله الثانيه الا تبالغ
المعارضه في التركيز على نسبه التصويت كما
عيار لفشل لمسار الرئيس المتحده اجراءاته
سعيد الصمت الذي هو علامه الرضا من اغلبيه
التونسيين الكانه التونسيون افضل حالا قبل
اجراءات قيس سعيد ومن قال انهم يريدون ايا
من الطبقه السياسيه التي حكمت او عارضت
قبل اجراءات قيس سعيد واذا كان قيس سعيد
يرفض الحواره مع المعارضين له الذين يصفهم
بالفاسدين للمفسدين الذين يستقفون بالخارج
فهل تريد المعارضه حقا الحوار معه
هذه الاسئله وغيرها نطرحها في هذه الحلقه
من الاتجاه المعاكس على ضيفين من تونس
لحبيب بوعجيله احد مؤسسي حراك مواطنون ضد
الانقلاب المعارض لاجراءات قيس سعيد
وجمال مارس عضو مكتب المكتب السياسي
للتيار الشعبي المؤيد لاجراءات 25 جويليه
نبدا نقاشه بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم من جديد معكم زين
العابدين توفيق
ونرحب مره اخرى بضيفينا من تونس لحبيب
بوعجيله وجمال مارس وابدا بك استاذ جمال
ما الرساله التي ينبغي ان يقراها الرئيس
من هذه النسبه المتدنيه للتصويت الادنى في
تاريخ تونس حتى في ايام بن علي في اي
انتخابات
مساء الخير
القناه والبرنامج طبعا رساله جاءت من
الشعب التونسي بمناسبه انتخابات تشريعيه
17 ديسمبر
تضمنت عزوفا غير مسبوق لكن قراءه هذا
الرقم لابد ان تم بني على همم دراسه
للمسار كامل الانتخابي بعد ايش يعني فتره
عليه يمكن حديث عليه في هذا الجانب تقريبا
في انتخابات
السيسي سنه 2011 كانت في حدود 4.3 مليون
وتدحرجت منذ ذلك التاريخ الى ثلاثه فاصل
الى اثنين الى ان تصل الى مليون وعديد
الاسباب في هذا الجانب كنا كحز التيار
الشعبي اصدرنا بيان وحملنا المسؤوليه لمن
يتحمل مسؤوليه في همم الجانب وهو طبعا
بالدرجه الاولى وحاليا هو رئيس الجمهوريه
باعتبار بعدد عوامل ضمن البيان واهم اها
هو بطئ مسار محاسبه رئيس الجمهوريه يتحمل
بطئ مسار المحاسبه للعشريه الفارته
باعتبارها
بوابه لترقيه المناخ السياسي والاجتماعي
والاقتصادي في راينا في تونس لان في غياب
المحاكمه وفي ظل معاقبه
وتاثير تاثيب الاثار القانوني على مختلف
الجرائم ارتكبت في حق الشعب التونسي سيبقى
المواطن الدوزي عازفا بل بل تحول التي
ربما بعض المحاكمات احيانا الى التندر همم
شبكيه التواصل الاجتماعي باعتبار يقع
ايقاف شخص ثم يقع اطلاق صراحه تبقى
محاكماته متاخره من الليل ثم يقع اذان
مثلا
الشعب التونسي يعني واخذ على خاطره ان
الرئيس لم يحاسب الناس ولم يحاكم اما ان
المشكله اكبر من ذلك هو ان الرئيس فشل
طبعا
انا ساخذ النقاط التي اراها سببا لهذا
العصور اذا المحاسبه اعتبرها عام من
اساسيا وبوابه مثل ما ذكرت بقطع النظاره
على تاثير وموقف المواطن التونسي هي بوابه
لترقيه المناخ السياسي والاقتصادي
والاجتماعي حتى يحاكم من الاجر التونسي
نقطه ثانيه هي الانهيار الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي الذي يعيشه المواطن اليوم كنا
يعلم ان الحليب غير متوفر بالمغازات
وبالسوق التونسيه كذلك الزيت السوق المواد
اساسيه يعتبرها المواطن في ظل غيابه ان
الوضع السيء سيء في في تونس ولكن من يتحمل
هل قيس سعيد بل اخفى الحليب القيس سعيد من
الاخذ ازيك اذا هذا سؤال يطرح على هذا
السؤال
هو الامر الناهي الحاكم بامره في تونس منذ
اجراءات 25 جوليا يعني هل هنالك احد غيره
يمكن لونه
قيس سعيد عندما اقدم على قرارات 25 جويليه
واتخذ هذا القرار الذي يعتبره حدود اللحظه
ونحن لازلنا نساند مسار 25 جويليه لانه
قرار ثوري يتحمل مسؤوليته ويعلم عندما
اقدم مع ذلك قرار ان الماليه العموميه في
وضعيه سيئه جدا ان الدوله غارقه في الديون
والقروض مع صندوق النقد الدولي واذكر
السيد الكريم هنا ان علاقتنا بصندوق النقد
الدولي قد قطعت منذ 39 وعادت مع حكم في
2012 ووقع اغلاق وكان برلمان العشريه
الفرده تقريبا اهم همم شغله هو المصادقه
على القروض وغلق الدوله في القروض اذا
كانت الوضعيه الاقتصاديه سيئه ينضاف الى
ذلك الفيتو والحصار الاقتصادي الداخلي
والخارج الذي فرض على حكومه الصعيد وعلى
سلطه الحاليه سنه 25 من غياب القروض من
غياب المساعدات
يمارسه
من خلال تحالفها لضرب المسار منذ واحد عشر
حتى هذه الان لا توجد حكومه همم عاشت همم
كل هذه السيطره على على الامور
كحكومه قيس سعيد منذ منذ قراراته في 25
جنيه يعني كل الحكم وحتى في في الزمن اطول
حكوميه يمكن حكومه يوسف الشاهد لكن كل
الحكومات الاخرى همم تشابه او اقل من
حكومات قيس سعيد لماذا همم وايضا هذه
الحكومات كانت تحارب اجراءات كثيره ومشاكل
كثيره همم ليس ليس همم اقل حاله التشرد من
السياسه الموجوده في تونس لكن القيس سعيد
انهى كل ذلك باجراءات 25 جوليا هو يحكم
بلا معقبه لحكمه فما المشكله لماذا لا
تريد ان تحمله انت مسؤوليه ما جرى
انا سيد كريم بصدر تحمله مسؤوليه مجاراه
في حدودي
سلطته في حدود ما قام به لان مره اخرى ان
التركه التي وجدها في 25 جويلا هي التركه
الثقيله على جميع المستويات الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه والاجتماعيه لانه لولا 24
جويليه مكانه 25 جويليه لاننا كلنا نعرف
حاله استنزاف الماليه العموميه خلال
العشيريه نحن مثل ما ذكرته في المقدمتكم
لم نكن في النعيم ولم نكن في نسبه نمو 6
او 5% خلال عشريه الفارته كانت القروض
وكاله المساعدات للحكومات الفارطه من
الخارج اليوم مذكرك سيد الكريم انه حتى
دوله عربيه ما وقفت الى جانب النظام
التونسي الذي يحكم الحال همم هناك دول
الاسده 10 مليون دولار الى البنك التركي
وديعه في البج وكذلك دوله اخرى خليجيه
خمسه مليون دولار ولم يسند ولو دولارا
واحدا الى حكومه قيس سعيد رغم الوعود ورقم
ما طلقه من ذلك اذا اضافه الى التضييق
والفيط والخارج على هذا الاقتصاد لو كانت
الامور الماليه الاقتصاديه يعني جيده في
تونس لكان بصار 25 لجبيليا ولا كان
الاقبال عن انتخابات في شكل اخر لو سمحت
واصل يعني النقاط التي احمل من خلالها
الحكومه الحاليه وهي يعني غياب القرارات
الثوريه غياب طرق معالجه بعض المسائل مثل
مساله الحرقه او ما تعرف بالهجره السريه
وملف جرجيس وكاله له تاثير في هذا الجانب
اذا اضافه الى التعيينات فيما في في مختلف
المناصب سواء على مستوى المحليات او مستوى
المركزي من معتمدين واولايات وغير ذلك
وحكومات نعتبرها الضعيفه وهناك عديده التي
بقيت شاغره في مؤسسه العموميه وغير ذلك كل
هذا ادى الى ضعف الدوله ادى الى دم اتخاذ
قرارات نعتبرها ثوريه لاصلاح المنظومه
واخرها قانون الماليه الذي صدر منذ يومين
والذي في جانب كبير منه خيبه الشعب
التونسي ولكن كما يقول المثل بكره هنا
اخاك لا بطل
الاستاذ الحبيب بوعجيلك كل ما يجري وحتى
هذه النسبه المتدليه الغير مسبوقه لتصويت
في الجوله الاولى للانتخابات التشريعيه هو
لان الشعب يرى ان قيس سعيد
امم يمضي بالجر الكافيه في اجراءاته وليس
لاسباب اقتصاديه
هذه هي الخلاصه الهزيله التي يستخلص بها
قيس سعيد
وانصاره همم نتيجه انتخابات 17 ديسمبر
والتي تسمى في اللغه السياسيه وضعيه
الانكار هذا مسار شعبي
تم التامر على زعيمه من طرف الدوله
العميقه من طرف ظروف الزمان والمكان ومن
طرف
الاعوان والاطراف التي كلفها قيس سعيد
التي كلفها المهدي يعني هذه الحاشيه التي
غادرت به فخاب ظن الشعبي في مساره والفضل
من حوله منتظرا نبيا اخر
يقيم نفس الرساله هذا هو الخطا
انقلاب 25 شيرين جويليه قلنا منذ اللحظه
الاولى انه لا يحظى بمسانده شعبيه بمعنى
ان هناك مجموعه من الاساطير المؤسسه
لاعتبار مسار 25 جويليه مسار تصحيح مطلوب
شعبيه نحن من 25 جويريه قلنا ليس صحيحا
الوضع الشعبي نعم كان قائما على انتعاظ
وقلق من عشريه انتقال ديمقراطي لم تحقق
انجازا اجتماعيا واقتصاديا لكن الشعب
التونسي كان يطالب بان يصبح هذا الانتقال
الديمقراطي محققا للانجاز الاجتماعي
والاقتصادي بطبقه سياسيه
جريئه ولكن ليس بالانقلاب على الديمقراطيه
والدليل على ذلك
ان الاسطوره المؤثر يوم 25 جويليه واللي
هي خروج الشعب
يعني محاوله للتشبه مثل في يونيو المصري
لم يصلوا الى ربع لم يصلوا الى ثمن لم
يصلوا الى سفر فاصل من اثبات يوم 25
جويليه 2021 ان هناك بشر على الارض ان
هناك شعب على الارض
ساعطيكم ماذا تم
وسائل الاعلام
مجموعه من الاذاعات توفيق صباحا
وتبدا في البث المباشر من شوارع فارغه
ويقولون نحن في انتظار هبوب
العاصفه الشعبيه التي ستطالب رئيس
الجمهوريه الشعبيه
ليست هناك مشروعيه شعبيه المشاركه كانت في
حدود الخمسه او تقريبا 6% بدون اثباتات
جاء الاستفتاء لم يصل في تقديرينا ولم
يحقق اكثر مما حققته انتخابات 17 سنه يعني
في اخر التحليل مقوله انه يمكن الانقلاب
على الشرعيه الدستوريه
وعشريه الانتقال الديمقراطي بمقوله
المشروعيه الشعبيه يعني هناك شعب طالب
وقال نعم يمكن ان ننقلب على الديمقراطيه
ويمكن ان ينقلب على الدستور هذه كذبه هذه
اسطوره مؤسسه
كاذبه ليس صحيحه الامر كان يتعلق بوجود
نعم امتعال شعبي لكنه شعب لم يقل انقلب
على الديمقراطيه
لم يخرج بعد ذلك لحبيب ولم يقل عن ذلك لم
يخرج لم يخرج صحيح لم يخرج 25 جويل او 26
او في 27 جويريه او في شهر اغسطس او في
بدايه شهر سبتمبر لم يخرج ليقول اريد ان
ادافع على الديمقراطيه بمعنى انه لم يقول
انا مع الانقلاب على الديمقراطيه ولكنه لم
يخرج ويقول انا اريد ان ادافع على
الديمقراطيه هذا ليس دليلا على انه يساند
الانقلاب ولكن ايضا ليس دليلا بالنسبه لنا
نحن كمعارضه لهذه الانقلاب ان الشعب
التونسي مستعد للدفاع عن الديمقراطيه
انطلق حركه مواطنون ضد الانقلاب
واستطاع ان يجسد على الارض شارعا سياسيا
شارع السياسي هو جزء من الشعب التونسي يعد
بالالاف
المؤلفه عالم امتداد 15 وقفه
لم يستطع في مقابلها الانقلاب عبر دعوه
الرئيس من داخل وزاره الداخليه الى ان
يجنن على الارض
جمهورا شعبيا اي شارع عن سياسيا اخر يقول
انا جزء من الشعب التونسي في مقابل ذلك
الجزر من الشعب التونسي الذي يقول هذا
القيامه
وهو ينفذ اجراءاته دون ان تستطيع
وقف هذه الاجراءات لا يحتاج الى شارع
السياسيه لا يحتاج الى من يقف ويخفون
لانه ماض في اجراءاته دون مشاكل
ليس هناك من هدف له
اذن انت لا تحتاج لشارع سياسي لان تعتبر
ان الشعب معك اين سيخرج الشعب معك في
المواقع التي قررتها انت يعني سيخرج لك في
الانتخابات انت تقول تظاهر ما شئتم انتم
بقى تظاهر ما جئتوا ما شئتم ساهزمكم
بخارطه الطريق التي اعددتها يعني ما هي
خريطه الطريق انت اعددت مواعيد انتخابيه
ثلاث مواعيد انتخابيه لشعبك الذي يناسبك
وسيخرج اليك دون دعايه وسيخرج اليك دون ان
تكون
دعايه الانتخابيه
ينتقل بها الى ضيفنا الاخر يفترض انه اذا
لا يحتاج الرئيس الى من يتظاهرون
ي- يبارك اجراءاته اذا كان ذلك صحيحا فانه
يحتاج الى ان يخرج الناس في المواعيد
الانتخابيه التي حددها في الاستشارات ال-
ال- استشاره الالكترونيه لم تكن ذلك
مشاركه كبيره في الاستفتاء حتى رغم ان اا
لجنه الانتخابات غيرت غيرت بعد ذلك او
عدلت نسبه ال- ال- المشاركه لكن في
النهايه هي 30% على دستور نحن نتحدث عن
الانتخابات دستور هذا الدستور ينبغي ان
يكون باغلبيه همم المواطنين ثم جاءت
الانتخابات التشريعيه استاذ جمال مارس
جاءت الانتخابات التشريعيه ولم يخرج الناس
اقل من 10% في القراءه الاولى من لجنه
الانتخابات هم عدلتها الى 11% اليس هذا
الدليل واضحا وضوح الشمس على ان الشعب غير
راضي عن هذه الاجراءات
بالنسبه الى المشروعيه الشعبيه لمصار 25
جويليه كانت ثابته واضحه يوم 25 جويل
لتحديدا عندما هب الشعب التونسي وخارجه
الى الشارع ورايين تلك المظاهر يعني تعبير
عن الفرحه بعد خبر
اتفضل استاذ جمال
بعد ان سايب الشعب التونسي تلك المشاهد
المقززه صلبه برلمان 2019 من تبادل العمق
ورشق الاموال ومختلف المظاهر وبعد ان
تحالفت لوبيات المال والسياسه والري على
الاقتصادي وادت الى ذلك البرنامج فكان رد
الفعل الي وطبيعي للشعب التونسي بان يخرج
وينتصر لقاره 25 جويليه باعتبارها وضعت
حدا لذلك المسار من يدعي انه خرج 15 وقفه
وقام باحتلال الشارع وان قيس سعيد ليس له
المشروعيه الشعبيه في المقابل هي عشرات
وعادات قليله في كل مره يضعفون في الارقام
لو كانت لهم قدره على احتلال الشارع
بالاعداد التي يدعو لها بعشرين ال 15000
كذلك لا افتكوا الحكم اليوم لنكون صالحين
انه لا وجود لقوه سياسيه او حزب سياسي
قادر على اخراج هذه الاعداد واقول الاجابه
الخلاص والمختلف في تسميه مجرد مجموعات
على الفيسبوك وجروبات هي يعني دورها فقدت
الخروج الى الشارع في اعداد محدوده جدا
وغير قادره اقول لهم انا رصيدكم غير كافي
لتح في الشارع او قيام ولو كانت لهم
القدره على ذلك لان اكلت لهوب كامل الحريه
في التلقل وعاقب مختلف الاجتماعات وكانوا
محدودين جدا ربما اليوم من النوادر ان
يقولوا ان 92% هم يعني ضد قيس الصعايد
وقال لهم ما مع مع المسار على الاخر طبعا
هذا خاطئ وخاطر جدا لان اعود مره اخرى الى
ان تدني هذا نسبه المشاركه والعذوبه يعود
بالاساس الى القانون انتخابه ويكمل فكره
الاولى قالوا انتخابي يتحمل في رئيس
الجمهوريه لانه لم يشارك مختلف الفئات
الاخرى الا في حدود ما ما ضيقه جدا سواء
400 تزك مع التعريف بالانظر او في اشاره
بقيه الشروط كذلك في الخارج وغيرها كانت
يعني المشاركه من حيث الترشحات وكذلك من
حيث نوعيه الترشحات كذلك اشاره التفرغ
الولد بالدستور اي انه تقريبا لا يمكن
للمحامي ان يترشح لا يمكن للطبيب الذي
يترشح لا يمكن للخبير المحاسب يترشح لان
لا يمكن له ان يغلق مكتبه ويتفرغ البرلمان
بين امام مختلف
الدول تسمح بيهرزدواجيه فقدت البوظه في
العمومي لا يمكنه ان يكون له صيغه نائب
موظف يعني هذه من الاشياء التي قلت لان
نوعيه المترشح هي لهذا العلاج على ان هذا
يتخلص
المرشحين لكن لماذا تقلص الناخبين بشكل
كبير هذه النقطه التي ذكرتها تقلص عدد
المترشحين لماذا تقلص الحديث عن
ها المواطنه التونسي المواطنه التونسي
ينظر الى خطاب هزيل ينظر الى مستوى محدود
للمرشحين طبعا هذا سين عكس علاء التوجه
الاقتراع لان المواطن سيقول لمن ساصوت لم
يجد الشخص المناسب الذي يمكن ان يملا كرسي
البرلمان في هذا الجانب مع احترامنا للبعض
كما هناك عديد الترشحات الضعيفه صغار
الموظفين صغار الفلاحين نحن في حيث التيار
الرئيس الذي يقول انه خلصت من العشريه
السوداء ليس للرئيس مشروعيه وهو طلب الناس
هو طلب الخروج اليس هذا يعني اليست كلمته
للناس كافيه اليس هو من خلص تونس وفق ما
قلت من العشريه السوداء اليس هو من يحفظ
اجراءاته شعبيه شارفه في تونس فلماذا لم
يسمع له الناس
نعم هاي على هذا المستوى له الشعبيه
الكبيره
وبنشاركه في الاستفتاء اعتقد ان استفتاء
على الدستور في حدود 30% في فصل 4% مع
التاكيد ان مساله القيراط الاهلي يعني خمس
سنين مليون اضيف اليه
وهو خطا نهايه الانتخابات
يعني هو طالب الناس بالخروج وبالتصويت
فلماذا لم يسمع له
لانه يؤيدون اجراءاته هل لانهم يرفضونه
قيس سعيد وكاله الاستجابه في حدود مليون
رغم
ترشحات ولقب عديده العوامل الاخرى
ووكد بره اخرى ان من يفهمون ولو الاختصاص
علماء الاجتماع
ان التصويت على الافراد يختلف كثيرا على
تصويت
لان الاله الحزبيه والماكينه الحزبيه كما
نقول في تونس غائبه في هذا الاطار وهي
التي تجعل الاضافه بخلال التوجه الى
الرئيس
لها رصيد بدليل انها لم تخرج الناس الى
الشارع
فاين نصود الرئيس ولماذا لم يتمكن رصيد
الرئيس من اخراج الناس الى صناديق
الاقتراع
هذا هو السؤال
الرئيس اخرج في حدود مليون انا افسر
العزوف من خلال جمله من العوامل هل رئيس
له اخطائه التي ارتكبها سواء في سن
القانون انتخابي بهذا الشكل سواء في مختلف
العوامل التي
تتعلق ببطئه 25 جويلي هذا ادى الى العزوف
لكن
النظام الانتخابي الجديد القائم على تصويت
على الافراد ليس هو نفسه القائم على افراد
كذلك التغيير
هذا كل يجعل
المشاركه والاله الحزبيه تغيير كذلك اذا
نظرنا الى العزوفه والتخلص من الفيل 2011
الى اليوم من اربعه مليون ثلاثه مليون هذه
كلها اسباب الهرم المنظومه السياسيه وتعرض
مشهد سياسي وعزوف المؤسسه التونسي على
الانتخابات وعليه السياسه هو مربوط
بالاساس مختلف
الاخر استاذ الاحباب
اذا كان الرقم الاول التي ذكرته لجنه
الانتخابات من ثمانيه في المئه فقط هم صوت
في الجوله الاولى همم
وامتنع اثنان وتسعون عن المشاركه فهذا لا
يعني ان انكم تحظون بتائيل 92% من الشعب
التونسي على العكس تماما انتم كما قال ليس
لديكم رصيد كافي لاخراج الناس في مظاهرات
تنهي هذه الاجراءات لقيس سعيد كما انهت
حكم بن علي في الثوره الثوره التونسيه لم
تفعل ذلك لانه ليس لديكم رصيد ايضا تمام
تمام
تماما تماما من يقول ان نسبه
يعني
ال 90% فلنفترض ان رقم هيئه الانتخابات
ليست مضخما من يقول ان نسبه 90% من
المقاتلين هو رصيد المعارضه السياسيه فهو
خاطئ واذا تهمت المعارضه الديمقراطيه ذلك
فهي تقع في الانكار انا قلت منذ البدايه
انو 25 جويريه يوم 25 جويليه ومتلاه الشعب
التونسي لم يكن
مساندا للانقلابي على الديمقراطيه ولكنه
لم يكن مدافع عنها لانه كان غاضبا ماذا
يجب ان يتم في مسار الاحداث يجب ان يكون
هناك شارعان متقابلان اذا كان الشعب بعيد
على هذه المعركه بين الانقلاب
والديمقراطيه ماذا يجب ان يجري على امتداد
الاشهر المواليه لعمليه انقلابيه يجب اولا
ما يسمى بالشوارع المتقاب وهي بالضروره
شوارع سياسيه تتقابله لكي اثبت ان لي شارع
سياسي وان لك شارع سياسي بشهاده الجميع
اعلاميه ان مواطنون ضد الانقلاب ثم جبهه
الخلاص اخرجت الالاف شارع سياسي لنفترض
ذلك انت لم تستطع اذا انت ليس لك شارع
سياسي اكتوبر
يوم ثلاث اكتوبر يوم 3 اكتوبر 2000 2021
يعني بعد تقريبا ثلاثه اشهر من الانقلاب
من داخل وزاره الداخليه دعاره رئيس
الجمهوريه انصار المسار انصار التصحيح
انصار الانقلاب الشعبي ان يخرج بالالاف
لكي يسوي غبيهم حل المجلس الاعلى للقضاء
لم يخرج احد
بعض عشرات جئنا احنا يوم 10 اكتوبر قلنا
تعالى الان سنعتبيره يوم الحزم في الشوارع
السياسيه المتقابله ليس لك شارع سياسي ولا
شارع السياسي بعد ذلك اصبح الصراع حول
النخبه السياسيه من معك من معك في هذا
المسار السياسه في البلدان تقاس بالنب
والاكاديميين والطبقه السياسيه والاحزاب
انت مين هي الاحزاب اللي معك
والمستعده للمشاركه في مشارك ومن هي
الاحزاب الرافضه رايتم من هي اللجان التي
صعدت الدستور نكيرات سياسيه او احزاب
الحقيقه علاقتها بالديمقراطيه تاريخيه
ايديولوجيا هي علاقه ليست جيده في مقابل
ذلك كل الاطراف السياسيه
التي بنت يعني حزبيتها
على الديمقراطيه بعد عشريه الانتقال كانت
بسقوف مختلفه تقول هذا انقلاب بعد ذلك الى
ماذا نمر بعد ذلك نمر الى الى
الاختبار بالصناديق في اختبار الصناديق
ثلاث مرات لم يذهب اليك هذا الشعب الذي
لفظ كل الطبقه السياسيه اذا سنفترض ان هذا
الشعب الذي لفظ كل الطبقه السياسيه والذي
لا يريد الوسائط والذي بنيت انت فكرتك في
البناء القاعدي على تبني هذا الميزان انه
الديمقراطيه سيئه ولا تؤسس الا بعلاقه
مباشره مع الشعب وانك جئت للمحاسبه التي
يريدها الشعب كان الشعب يريد ان يضع
الطبقه سياسيه في السجون صحيح والثاني اذا
انت جئت لمقاومه الفساد واراضي عن هذا
الاهم انت جئت للانجاز الاجتماعي
والاقتصادي لانه هناك اموال كثيره موجوده
واكلها اكلتها هذه الطبقه السياسيه وانت
سترجعها لتطعم الشعب من جوع وتؤمنه من خوف
هذا كله ثبت انه مجرد خرا
ذهبنا بعد ذلك الى الاختبار بالصندوق لم
تقدم شيئا اكثر من ذلك اصبح الان هناك
مزاج شعبي يستعيدوا شيئا فشيئا الا علاقه
دعني اقول الحميميه مع الاطراف السياسيه
اصبح عمود انه كان من المفروض
نعم ان نصبر على انتقال الديمقراطي فيه
طبقه سياسيه فاشله يجب ان تتجدد في طبقه
سياسيه انشغلت بصراعاتها نعم يجب ان تحدد
اوليات اولياتها فيه دعنا نقول يعني نوع
من الملل منها ولكن نحن نلحظ في الشارع من
المواطنين العاديين ليس هذه المسيسيين
اصبحنا نلحق في الشارع بعد اشهر من هذا
الانقلاب ان المواطنين يستوقفوننا من نحن
نحن الطبقه السياسيه التي دافعت على
الانتقال الديمقراطي اذا المفروض نحن
الطبقه السياسيه التي انتجتها العشريه
السوداء التي كريهه هذا الشعب هذا الشعب
اصبح يعترضنا في الشارع ويقول يجب ان تجد
حلا مع هذا الرجل يجب ان تجد حلا ما اعلى
الانقلاب اذا لم يعد هناك شعب في على
الاقل في صفته الغالبه لم يندم على انه
سكت على عدم الدفاع يعني الديمقراطيه
يبدو ان الشعب التونسي شعر فعلا انه كان
عليه ان يدافع على ديمقراطيه بحد الادنى
عوضا ان يسكت عن الانقلاب على شرعيه انفرد
بها فرد واحد
وجند معه نخبه لا سياسيه بدون سيره سياسيه
او نخبه على كل حال علاقتها بالديمقراطيه
محدوده ثم بعد ذلك لا فضها ثم بعد ذلك
افرضها ثم بعد ذلك لم يشركها من كتبوا له
الدستور
خرجوا بعد ذلك وقالوا هذا ليس دستورنا هذا
انقلاب لم يستطع ان يؤثر لنفسه حزاما
سياسيا حتى من الطبقه السياسيه التي تدعي
ايديولوجيا انها طبقه معاديه لعشريه
الديمقراطيه ولي عشريه ربيع الخرائط
الربيع العبري وما ادري شو هذا انقلاب لم
يستطع لا ان يجلد نخبه سياسيه ولا ان يجند
انه اقام عليه مشروعيه انقلابه على
الشرعيه وهو تجند الشعب كان من المفروض ان
النظام شعبوي انقلاب شعبوي يخرج الشعب فيه
بالالاف ويقول له عن محارب ويقول له لا
تستقل ويقولون له يلا كثير واحنا واحنا
وراءك يا قائد دمرها
يمارسون معه الزحف الاخضر حتى هذا لم يوجد
يا صديقي اذا نحن امام انقلاب ادعى يعني
هو انه مسلم مشاعر شعبيه قال له هو ده
الشعب لا ليست هذه مشاعري يعني
هذه النقيه
اريد ان اسال عن السيد جبل مارس
الزعماء الشعبويين في العالم والرئيس
باعتراف الجميع يتمنى خطاب الشعبويه من
البدايه
الانتخابيه لكن ليس هنالك من يدعمه لم نرى
مثلا همم حتى همم لو تحدثنا عن الولايات
المتحده ترامب له مؤتمرات وله جماهيريه
وله جمهور ثابت لا يتغير كذلك في دول
اوروبا اليمين الفرنسي اليمين الايطالي
لكن هذا غير موجود
في حاله قيس سعيد هو فقط يفترض ان الشعب
معه لكن لم نرى ذلك باعيوننا في الواقع
حتى النخبه القريبه منه قفزت الواح التلو
الاخر كما قلت في المقدمه بدايه من محمد
عبده الذي دعا الى اتخاذ اجراءات
استثنائيه ثم صادق بالعيد الذي قال ليس
هذا هو الدستور الذي كلفته بوضعه ونشر
نسخه من دستوره ثم نسمع نور الدين الطبوبي
الذي في البدايه تحدث عن اجراءات لابد
منها ثم تحدث عن
مراجعه للمسار ثم ها هو يقول ان قيس سعيد
هو المشكله وان الرساله من الشعب التونسي
في هذه الانتخابات كان ينبغي ان يلتقطها
الرئيس التونسي لكن لا توجد رجاحه عقل وصل
الى ان استخدم هذه الكلمه يعني السؤال هو
على اي اساس انت تؤيد اجراءات الرئيس بعد
كل من قفزه من سفينته طيله العام الماضي
بالنسبه الى مساله غياب الشعب وغياب
المواطنين في المشهد السياسي سواء مع قيس
سعيد او مع المعارضه اقول ان المعارضه
ايضا بهذا الخطاب
الخشبي الذي في قطيعه كامله مع الشعب
التونسي خطاب يتوجه بدرجه الاولى الى خارج
قبل الدخل
واكد مره اخرى انه يدعيه من الارقام
من نقاط قوه قيس سعيد ان له معارضه بهذا
الشكل في قطيعه كامله مع الشعب التونسي
تتوجه الى الخارج قبل الداخل وهذا ثابت
ومؤكد اذا بالنسبه الى مسار 25 جوليا وما
يدعم قيس سعيد وهو بالاساس الاهداف
الاساسيه التي بني منها
تاسس عليها مثلا 25 جوليا وكان السؤال
الحارق والسؤال الذي يطرح في مختلف
النقاشات هو هل ان مسار 25 جويليه بدايته
سياسي ام يجب ان ياخذ الاعتبار وبدرجه
اوله بدرجه عاجله المساله الاقتصاديه
والاج طبعا المسار 25 جوليا كدا بالاساس
في البدايه السياسي وركز على اعاده بناء
المؤسسات التي تخربت خلال العشريه السوداء
من هيئه الانتخابات ومجلس على القضاء
واعاده الدستور بعد ان ثبت الدستور الى
ذلك المشهد السياسي اصبحنا نتحدث على
الرئاسات ثلاثه في تونس اصبح للتحدث همم
اصبحنا نشاهد برلمان مهزله كل هذا ادى الى
اعاده البناء وكان سيطره المسجد السياسي
ومثل التشريعيه اكثر من اللازم وادت الى
طول المسار فكان طول النصارى طبعا هو يعني
معه استعداد اعتداد البث الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه مثلا تحدثت منذوحيد ومع
الاخلاق ومع الفيت وعلى حول المساعدات
وخلق همم يعني همم اقتصاد منتج واقتصاد
يعني وطني بذلك بشكل كذا لابد من اللجوء
الى صندوق النقد الدولي كذا لابد الى مزيد
يعني شاكر من اشكال التهريه لهذا المسار
عبر المساء الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه الى ان
وصلنا الى هذه النتيجه بينما اعتقد ان
موسى
مبدئيه نحن والبدايه وجدنا 60 70% مما
نبحث عنه في الدوله التونسيه وفي بناء هذه
الدوله مجسم صلبه سواء الدستور صلبه
القرارات اعتبرها في جانب كبير منها ثوري
في عهد بناء والقطع مع السابق واعاده
تجذيب وبناء همم
مثل مشهد سياسي يختلف على ذلك المشهد
المقزز السابق بخصوص بعض من ذكرتها يعني
سواء الصادق بالعيد او رئيس الاتحاد
بالنسبه لصدق بالعيد كان مؤتمن العداله
وبعض الشخصيات
قال ان هذا انقلاب وان هو هذا ليس هو
المسار
سياتي على ذلك رجاء ان تتركني فكرتي بان
الطبوبي عفوا بالعيد لم يكن امينا على
محتوى الحوار الوطني الذي دار حول الدستور
وكانت مخرجات والخلاصه التي تنتهي بذلك
دستور تختلف بنسبه 90% عما اداره من
الحوار وعما يعني ضمنا من مختلف المقترحات
مختلفه الاطراف من المنظمات وشخصيات
واحزاب ضمنت فكان لا بد من وضع ذلك
الدستور الذي لا اريد ان اقول فيه اكثر من
ذلك ما قال هو الدكتور فرنسا هناك من قال
هو دستور الاتي بالخارج فكانت ال- اا
اعاده بناء الدستور وفقا توجهات وخيارات
ونحن نؤكد مره اخرى كحز التيار الشعبي
تقدمنا بعديد الاقتراحات المكتوبه
الجمهوريه ووجودنا فيها كثير صلبه
القطعه بعد البرلمان يعني
التونسيه والعوده الرئاسي مع توفيق باختلف
في المحاذير اللي على الدم عوده التاتوريه
كذلك ان الرجوع الى النظام الاقتراع صلبه
الافراد في دورتين خلافا الى نظام القوائم
لدى تلك المهاجر والكوارث يضعون من يشاءون
صلب القوائم ويقع مرورهم بتعله انه ينتمي
لهذا يجعل له دعم هذا الخيارات مع تحميل
رئيس الجمهوريه يعمل مقاطعه يا الضيف لم
تقاطعه وتركته لمده 10 دقائق يتكلم ارجو
ان تتركني على راحتي وخلي يتكلم
الموضوع اعتقد انه اسلوب نعرفه ومؤثر على
الخطاب ارجوكم اريد ان افهم فقط
ارجو ان تتركني انهي فكرتي يعني انا انهي
فكرتك سريعا لانه لدينا لدينا اسئله حول
حول ماذا كريم
هذا ارجو ان تتركني انهي فكرتي بالشكل
المريح مثلا لما تركت الضيف تفضل
بالنسبه لمساله اتحاد الشغل اتحاد الشغل
هو مؤسسه وطنيه لها كل المصداقيه لها كل
الاحترام في خصوص دوره النقابي والاجتماعي
اضافه الى دوله سياسي منذ الاستعمار
ودورها في التحرير بناء مثلا الدوله
الوطنيه
وتجربه التعارض وغيرها كان لها دور كبير
لكن لا يمكن ان نفي عليها دوله سياسيه في
المقابل لها حساباتها الضيقه في خصوص همم
اعاده سيطرتها وخروجها في المسجد السياسي
في تونس لان الاتحاد غيبا خلال وتغير بقى
وتغيب هذا يبقى النقاش لانه لم يحضر دعي
الى حوار دستوره لم يحضر كان مسانده ل 25
جويليه ويقول انه حتى في هذه على مختلف
قرارات الجمهوريه ومصار 25 جويده لا يعني
العوده الى 24 جويده في فتره ما وقع
الحديث عن الخيار الثالث اليوم رئيس
البرلمان وله مشاكله الخاصه وله حساباته
الضيقه ولا يتسعوا المجال لذكرى ولكن
الاتحاد الشغل همم معه المنظمات الوطنيه
بعد رساله ال- اا الشعب التونسي من خلال
العزوف على الانتخابات من حقنا همم من حق
هذه المؤسسات سواء هيئه المحاميه سواء رد
حق الانسان او اتحاد الشغل ان يدعو الى
حوار وطني في ظل معطيات وفي ظل ليس الحوار
الذي رايناه سابقا والذي غايته والتقاط
بعض الصور وبغايه تقاسم الكعكه وغير ذلك
نحن همم معه حوار وطني تشارك في القوه
الوطنيه الصادقه مع اقصاء كل ما خرب
الدوله التونسيه في الفتره السابقه من اجل
استرداد يعني بعض مكونات الدوله من اجل
انقاذ تونس في الاتجاه الصحيح على مستوى
الاقتصادي والاجتماعي والسياسي طيب تمام
يعني كل هؤلاء الناس لديهم حسابات ضيقه
همم وهذا ينعكس على مواقفه بالنسبه
للاتحاد التونسي للشغل ونور الدين وهو
صحيح دعى الى مبادره الى حوار لكن لم
يتحدث عن لا جبهه الخلاص ولا عن مواطنون
ضد الانقلاب ولا ايه عن القوه السياسيه
المعارضه لقيس سعيد فتقرا تصريحات نور
الدين الطبوبي
على من تحدث ما يهمنا اين تتموقع الان
منظمات المجتمع المد
ني على الانقلاب صمطت عليه كما صمت الشعب
الشعب صمت على الانقلاب ولم يدافع عن
الديمقراطيه لماذا قال هذه الطبقه
السياسيه انت لم تؤدي لي شيئا لم تقدم لي
شيئا انا لست مستعدا للدفاع على
الديمقراطيه لم تنجز هذه رساله مهمه يجب
ان تستوعبها المعارضه الان الان وليس غدا
يوم 17 ديسمبر الشعب التونسي قال لهذه
المعارضه طيب انا بعد عام ونصف
لن اخرج لمسانده الانقلاب في صندوق
الاغترا ولكني الان في انتظار صياغه
بدائركم ايها الديمقراطيون تغيير خطاباتكم
الاعتراف باخطاءكم وانا ربما اكون مستعدا
ان اخرج للدفاعي على مرحله سياسيه جديده
بالضروره ستكون ديمقراطيه في مواجهه
الانقلاب لاني فعلا اكتشفت ان هذا
الانقلاب الشعبي
لم يحقق لي حتى ما وعد به هو والانجاز
الاجتماعي والاقتصادي من هنا جاءت
المنظمات والاتحاد
العام التونسي شغل يشعر بمزاج الشعب
التونسي يدرك تماما ان هذا النظام
الانقلابي لم يعد نظاما شعبيا ولم يكن
شعبيا الاول لكن يا سيدي الكريم تاكد الان
انه ليس شعبيا الشعب يوجه الرساله اذا على
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل ان يستخلص
الدرس ويقول هذه مرحله الانتاج انتهت ليس
بمعنى ان تسقط انت تعرف سقوط مرحله يتطلب
سياقات عديده الذي يقول انتم لم تستطيعوا
اسقاطها الانقلاب لو كنتم بالالاف الالاف
لا تسقط النظام الانقلابيه المسدوده
بالقوه الصلبه للدوله
الالاف تؤكد ان هناك شارع سياسي وبعد ذلك
هناك شروط اخرى عديده من بين احساس
المنظمات المدنيه واساسا المنظمه الشغاله
بانه هذه المرحله يجب ان تنتهي ليس هناك
داء ان يتكلم الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
على مواطنون ضد الانقلاب او على جبهه
الخلاص المهم انه وصل الى الاستخلاص الذي
وصل اليه مواطنون ضد الانقلاب
منذ صباحي 25 جويريه ان المستهدف هو
الديمقراطيه وبديلها ليس انجازا اجتماعيا
ولا اقتصاديا ولا بلاء لنظام الوطني ولا
استرجاع السياده ولا شيء من هذا كله انما
هو النظام بلا افاق نظام شعبوي بلا وفوق
يريد فقط ان يغلق قوس
الحد الادنى من الديمقراطيه عندما يتكلم
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل معنى ذلك انه
قال بوضوح بعد عام ونصف ان ما قاله
مواطنون ضد الانقلاب وما قالته جبهه
الخلاص التي توقعت ان الشعب سيخرج في
الانتخابات ويقول انا لست معنيا بها يعني
بعباره اوضح سيقول في خارطه الطريق قيس
سعيد انا لست مع هذا المسار ادرك الاتحاد
السياسيه يبداوا اولا الناس اللي تملك
رؤيه استراتيجيه وتملك قدر ادنى من
الاخلاقيه السياسيه التمسك بالشرعيه يعني
احنا مواطنين ضد الانقلاب من اكثر
الناقلين للعشريه من اكثر الناقدين
للاحزاب التي كانت تحكم بمختلف توجهاتها
ولكن لنا كنا نتسلح اولا بال الاستشرافيه
هل يمكن لديمقراطيه قاصره غير منجزه
ان يعوضها انقلاب
يذهب بالبلاد الى انسداد وفوق اذا كانت
الديمقراطيه قادره على اصلاح نفسها
الانقلابات لا تستطيع ان تذهب الا الى
الانهيار هذا قلناها من اللحظه الاولى
احذروا يا جماعه
هل ترسل الشغل نور الدين الطبيب بالطالب
الرئيس بان يلتقط اللحظه بان يفهم الرساله
بان يقول انا اخطات والشعب سيسامحه هل
تعتقد ان الرئيس سيفعل ذلك هل نتوقع في
المستقبل بعد هذه النتائج اي تغيير في
مسار قيس سعيد
طبعا الاتحاد اعتقد خلافه لم يذهب اليكم
لا يعطي
لا يوجه حديثا كتاب في اتجاه المساله
الديمقراطيه لان التي لان المثل
الديمقراطيه يعني من الشيء الاحزاب
السياسيه من شان المجتمع السياسي وال
الاتحاد دوره بالاساس الاجتماعي
وفي الجانب الاقتصادي فالازمه اقتصاديه
اجتماعيه والمسار السياسي طبعا هو همم
يحكموا الدستور وتحكمه الانتخابات وما الى
ذلك لان لا فائده نتحدث على المساله
الديمقراطيه كذلك داخل الاتحاد من الداخل
في خصوص همم هذا الجانب اذا ما انتظره كنا
كذلك حسب الشعب توجهنا ببياننا لرئيس
الجمهوريه والى الشعب التونسي بضروره بعد
رساله الشعب التونسي خلال العزف على
الانتخابات الفرق ان يلتقي رئيس الجمهوريه
طبعا اللحظه وان ننتظر قرارات الثوريه على
مستوى الاخلالات والهزات التي شابت مثلا
25 جميلا سواء في بطء مسار المحاسبه سواء
في اتخذ همم
انا اسف للمقاطعه همم يعني انت تريد
للرئيسا يلتقط اللحظه هل هل المعارضه يمكن
ان تلتقط اللحظه ايضا استاذ الحبيب بعجينه
هل المعارضه مستعده لحوار مع الرئيس
باختصار في 20 ثانيه
اولا الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل نعم
تحرك عندما تبين ان هذا الانقلاب لا
يستطيع ان ينجز حتى على المستوى الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي والادهى من ذلك انه مش لن
يستطيع ان ينجز سيعصف بالمكاسب الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه عندها تحرك الاتحاد ولكن ماذا
قال الاتحاد
هناك ازمه سياسيه
للحوار اذا هو اقر بانه هناك ازمه سياسيه
ثانيا رئيس الجمهوريه
يتحاور مع احد شكرا رئيس الجمهوريه الذي
عاصف بالشرعيه لن لن
الزمخشريه لن يتحاور مع احد عام ونصف
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل وهو يستجدي
الحوار معه عمرو يوسف
ومساندوه يستجدون اللقاء معه
شكرا جزيلا واحد مؤسسه مواطنون ضد
الانقلاب المعارض الاجراءات قيس سعيد
ونشكر جمال مارس عضو المكتب السياسي
للتيار الشعب المؤيد لاجراء 2500
هذا لكم مشاهدينا نهايه هذه الحلقه من
الاتجاه المعاكس ان شاء الله يعود اليكم
الزميل فيصل القاسم الاسبوع المقبل في
امان الله
[موسيقى]